a family grieving all over again
five years after his untimely death kia
de los santos remains had to be exhumed
his graves leaves expiring along with
scores of others killed during a war on
drugs launched by then philippine
president rodrigo duterte
kian's uncle randy has made it his
mission to help other families
i wanted to reach out to families who
were big teams like us i learned from
visiting wigs that their loved ones did
not shoot as the police claim
kian was 17 years old when police
accused him of being a drug runner
they said they killed him in
self-defense but security footage proved
otherwise
only one drug war related murder by
police has resulted in a conviction that
of kian de los santos out of thousands
of debts the justice department is
currently investigating just 52 cases
yet the government insists the country's
justice system is working
president ferdinand marcos jr has vowed
the less bloody campaign against illegal
narcotics but he's ruled out rejoining
the international criminal court which
is investigating his predecessor's
administration for possible crimes
against humanity
what we're saying is we have an
investigation here and it's ongoing so
why do we have to have that
human rights advocates have been working
to uncover more evidence of
extrajudicial killings dozens of bodies
that have been exhumed have been brought
to dr raquel fortune one of only two
forensic pathologists in the philippines
so far i have seen about nine cases
where doctors signed the shooting case
as natural
hypertension sepsis pneumonia those
things
but very clearly to you they were not
natural causes oh yes definitely i'm
seeing
fractures mostly head shots
dr fortune says she can only hope her
work will help bring justice
but for families of victims at the very
least
it's closure that has been missing for
years
barn below al jazeera manila